it doesn't matter where you live in the
world everyone loves a good animated
movie but sometimes jokes get lost in
translation tons of movies get altered
to relate to their worldwide audiences
watch until the very end to find out
which Disney movies title was teamed due
to being inappropriate in another
country I loved you in fairy dream
adventure part 7 okay bye I love you The
Incredibles
you might remember mr. Incredibles
archenemy from the beginning of the
Incredibles he was a french-speaking
thief named bon voyage he crashes
through a brick wall to steal his latest
target his weapon of choice is he you
guessed it bombs and he keeps getting
away it's the failed attempt to capture
him that makes mr. incredible get a
bunch of bad press bon voyage his name
is a play on the phrase bon voyage which
means good journey in French it's
something you might say to someone
before they go on a trip it's pretty
funny because he uses bombs and always
gets away you would think they would
keep the name the same in France right
wrong in France bomb voyages name was
changed to full amour it means something
like crazy love in English the French
version also doesn't translate a lot of
the stuff he says in the subtitles only
a few phrases show up he says mr.
incredible little oath and your outfit
is totally ridiculous
we're definitely glad they chose to keep
this hilarious line it's one of the
funniest ones the villain has to offer
Edna mode would be so mad if she heard
him bon voyage
oops we need full amour is voiced by
Patrick Osmond he's a super famous
french voice actor who dubbed Michael
Keaton's lines in the 1989 Batman movie
Zootopia Zootopia came out in 2016 and
it was an overnight success this movie
was all about a perfect world we're
talking animals live together in peace
predators and prey got along just fine
well mostly there was a lot of
discrimination between predators and
prey the message in the movie about
accepting everyone was amazing but if
you speak about Zootopia - a friend from
another country they might have no idea
what you're talking about
Zootopia comes from the word utopia that
means a perfect world but you might have
noticed that Zootopia is actually a huge
city
Disney filmmakers realize that Zootopia
might not market well to other audiences
so in a few countries the name is
zootropolis that comes from the word
metropolis which is a much better word
to describe the movie setting so which
countries have this alternative title
you might be surprised the United
Kingdom is one of them even though they
speak English there too a lot of the
Nordic countries like Norway and Finland
also call it zootropolis so do Italy
Spain in Albania trance on the other
hand chose to stick with Zootopia think
that's crazy
Germany for some reason chose to change
the title to zoo mania it's the only
country with that name monsters
University when you're translating a
movie into another language things get
complicated and if you have a whole joke
based on spelling it gets even harder we
can't understand her she's from the
other studio ah this is exactly what
happened in monsters University you
remember Randall Boggs right in monsters
Inc he was the villain he was trying to
create a scream extractor that bordered
on a torture device he hated Mike and
Sulley so much because they were the
best at their job but in monsters
University we see a different side to
Randall he was a total outcast who
really wanted friends at the scare games
he tried to make some buddies he brought
cupcakes which is always a win in our
book the cupcakes spelled out be my pal
later the cupcakes gets stuffed under
randall shirt and the letters combined
to spell out Layne here's why this just
wouldn't work in other countries how
maybe another word for friend in English
but it doesn't always have a translation
in some countries he would need a lot
more letters to say the same basic thing
that's so a lot more cupcakes on top of
that the letters need to form an insult
and pulling that off isn't always easy
so for the International versions the
cupcakes go from having smiley faces to
sad faces instead the jokes might be way
less funny but it still works and the
rest of the movie is hilarious missing
out on one joke isn't that big of a deal
inside out Pixar got into some seriously
deep themes when they released inside
out they turned human emotions into
character
and it was amazing we left the toilet
seat up what is it woman what but there
was a lot of stuff in this movie that
had to be changed for other countries
the title was different in other places
and a few scenes were totally changed
but one of the changes had to do with
languages sometimes Disney and Pixar
will change signs and words to fit other
languages sometimes they leave it in
English and just use subtitles but they
had a whole new challenge with inside
out before they go into abstract thought
bing-bong reads a sign that says danger
this trunk goes from left to right as he
points out the letters D ang prove it to
you but did you know that not all
languages are read from left to right
and some of these are major languages
like Arabic Hebrew and Farsi in the
countries where they speak these
languages
bing-bong Strunk movements would it make
any sense
so animators changed it this truck moves
from right to left it's pretty cool that
they can make little changes like that
that way everyone understands what's
happening dolphin finding dory sometimes
movies in other countries are released
with subtitles other times
voice actors will dub another language
over the original finding Dory doesn't
have too many international changes no
major scenes had to be reanimated but
there is one big difference in a few
versions at the marine life Institute
the narrator at the park is Sigourney
Weaver
I'm Sigourney Weaver she's a super
famous actress known as the sight by
Queen she's best known for her roles in
alien and avatar and she's definitely
famous around the world even though
she's well known globally a few
countries changed the narrator France
had a well known news anchor play her
part Mexico had an astronaut voice the
role Pixar wanting to include other
celebrities in the film these are called
meta cameos the actors voice themselves
but they don't actually appear in the
film all we hear are their voices even
if you heard Ellen's voice a story you
might have heard a celebrity from your
country in those scenes we think that's
pretty cool which celebrity would you
have liked to hear as the marine life
Institute narrator up up is easily
Pixar's most heart-wrenching movies in
the montage of Carl and Ellie's life we
see how much Ellie wanted to go to
Paradise Falls it's a beautiful place in
South Amer
according to the movie and it has an
ethnic name Paradise Falls sounds like
the perfect place throughout the montage
we see them putting money in a jar
labeled Paradise Falls they're trying to
save up for the trip as best as they can
but things keep happening and they have
to spend the money Ellie passes away and
never gets to go to Paradise Falls so
Karl decides later in life to retire
there lots of times signs and notes are
translated into other languages for
international purposes but not in this
case rather than translate the piece of
paper the animators did something
totally different there's a sketch
picture of Paradise Falls on the jar if
you watch this movie outside of the US
you'll just see a drawing that a young
Ellie made we don't know how animators
decided what to translate and what to
completely replace these are some pretty
subtle changes but when Disney films
title meant something totally gross in
another country keep watching to find
out which one ratatouille
okay so I may have replaced words with a
picture but in ratatouille things got
translated ratatouille is all about a
rat named Remi he loves to cook he's the
most passionate chef we've ever seen
seriously he needs his own show on the
Food Network he wants nothing more than
to be a famous chef and make delicious
food for people but he's a Roden he
befriends a cook named linguini who
isn't that great in the kitchen
linguini works at a famous restaurant
that's been receiving poor reviews from
critics Remi and linguini worked
together to make new exciting food
France is known for being the food
capital of the world
French people love food and they're good
at making it it was the perfect place to
set the film but everyone in the movie
speaks English it was translated into
French but it wasn't just the voice
tracks that changed the letter Remi
finds and reads was translated to French
too not every country translated the
texts because Remi does proceed to read
it out loud but since it took place in
France they changed the handwriting to
honor the culinary capital inside out
inside out might have made more changes
for international audiences than any
other Pixar film but one of the coolest
changes it's the title inside out makes
total sense to English speakers it
us know that things are happening inside
of Riley it also tells us that emotions
are the main characters instead of the
people it's a pretty clever title but
that breeze doesn't translate well into
other languages and some places have
very different but equally awesome
titles in Denmark the movie is called
deep inside that sounds like it could be
a horror movie in Germany it's called
everything is upside-down that also
translates as everything is wild if you
live in Brazil or Portugal you might
know the movie has fun mind Saudi
Arabians speakers know it as heart and
minds the Russian title translates to
head breaker or jigsaw China and Taiwan
have three different titles but keep in
mind that these are direct translations
there's the great team inside head
turning inside head and play with friend
of inside Polish people on the other
hand call the movie it doesn't fit
inside the head whereas Mexico calls it
intense mind Japanse is pretty obvious
it's just called inside head who knew
there were so many alternate titles to
inside out I loved you in fairy dream
adventure part 7 ok bye I love you
Zootopia news anchors are pretty
important people no matter where you
live in the world do you get to know the
faces that bring you your news news
anchors might not be Hollywood famous
but they do become a sort of local
celebrity if you deliver national news
you have one of the most recognizable
faces in your country in Zootopia they
really wanted to get this point across
news anchors are supposed to feel
familiar so this is where Zootopia makes
its biggest international change this
seems what the news anchors looks
totally different depending on the
country the animators replaced one
anchor with the most recognizable
familiar animal for each location USA
Canada and France all had a moose anchor
but those are weird animals to kids in
China they got a panda journalist
instead Australia New Zealand got a
koala and Japan got something equally
adorable
they had it to nuki Brazil completes the
news anchor with a Jaguar the best part
is that in some countries these
characters are voiced by actual
journalists that's so awesome
Coco Coco is all about family and
following your dreams the beautiful
animation of this Mexican inspired movie
still gives us goosebumps
this story follows Miguel who wants to
play music but his family has banned it
for generations he ends up in the
afterlife on the night of Dia de los
Muertos or Day of the Dead there he
discovers the truth about his family's
dark past the movie is named after
Miguel's great-grandmother her name is
de couro but she goes by Coco she's very
old and doesn't have a great memory but
she is the last person who remembers her
father if she forgets and the family
doesn't honor him they'll disappear from
the afterlife forever the Coco means
something totally different in
Portuguese it basically means something
very gross that you do in the bathroom
you sue in Brazil they had to change the
title no one wants to see a movie named
after number 2 they call it Viva life is
a party and since you can't call your
grandma bathroom named Coco's name has
changed to Enya's in that version we're
so glad they caught that translation
error before they released it what's
your most favorite Pixar movie ever tell
us in the comments give this video a big
thumbs up if you love animated movies
and make sure to subscribe to the themes
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]